hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in Chapter 12 of the categories
Aristotle is going to explore what he
tells us at the beginning are four
distinct senses to the term prior this
comparative term saying one thing is
prior in relation to another as we're
going to see by the end he does a
typical move for Aristotle which is to
say upon consideration there's actually
five so we've got an extra one in here
that we'll discuss as well but he he
lays it out originally in terms of four
main meanings and the first meaning is
in his view the the closest to the core
of the term he says that it is the
primary there was most primary meaning
and by the time that we get down to the
bottom you see we're really stretching
the term in some respect he attributes
this to the common people in the way
that they talk about things but he will
explore it anyway so the first type of
priority where we've got one thing being
prior to another he says is one thing is
is older or one thing is more ancient
the Greek terms here are Presbyterian
you know older was the word that we
actually get elder or Presbyterian and
Pelayo their own comparative term more
ancient and closer to the origin all
right so we can talk about things being
more ancient than than others so
Aristotle you know for example is
ancient literature or ancient philosophy
by comparison to say Descartes or by
comparison to a contemporary philosopher
like Alistair McIntyre right Descartes
would be older or more prior than
MacIntyre would as well we can set them
out like that we can say that I am older
than most of my students we can even
reverse this and say well I run into a
student who's 80 years old that student
is older than than me Aristotle thinks
that this is the the
a most proper sense of the term but then
we get other things as well
and now it starts to get more
interesting I think he says when the
order of being cannot be reversed and
this cannot be reversed is he actually
translating an interesting Greek term
may anti-stress phone aunty strophe is
when we have you know in poetry or in
singing things opposed to each other
Aristotle will also use this term aunty
Stefan to say that you know rhetoric is
a counterpart or an outy strove to
dialectic there's a big discussion and
his book the rhetoric about exactly what
that means
so when there's the possibility of sort
of reversing this or responding to it he
says in some cases in the order of being
to a nigh at the word to be in Greek
when there can't be reversed at all with
one thing following the other then one
thing really is prior to the other he
uses a mathematical example he says when
it comes to numbers one is prior to two
and it's not just that you know when
you're a kid you learned one two three
or anything like that there's a priority
that is a conceptual or a metaphysical
priority to oneness to unity as opposed
to duality or Tunis you want to put it
right so you can think one without
thinking to is one way you can put it
but you can't have two without one
so he says provided it is that to exist
it follows that one must exist this is
what he's talking about as a
relationship in terms of being the
existence of one on the contrary does
not imply that of two I mean it'd be
hard to see what kind of number system
you could have without without two but
we can think about this in terms of
other numbers one is prior to 638 you
can do a lot in numbers without getting
to 638 right but you can't have 638
without one or indeed without the other
numbers
before it so there's a priority there as
well so he says lots of two things we
call that one prior which proceeds in
irreversible sequence so that's a turn
that's a sense of the term it's kind of
close to this this other one right and
then he brings up now we're getting a
little bit looser in any ordering he
says in any toxis taxi and is just the
accusative for a form of the word toxis
which means an arrangement or ordering
and here he gives examples drawn from
his own experience of Sciences and
speeches let's start the speeches part
first when people are arranging a
composition for public speaking they are
putting things into a kind of order and
Aristotle thinks and he's actually more
or less right on this that you're not
going to be a very effective speaker if
you just get up and start jumbling words
together and you know hope that people
get the idea now it's better if you
arrange them so for example a speech
should have something like an
introduction you know sometimes they
call this an X or T you know but it
should have it should have an
introduction and then there should be
the body of the speech and then there
should be some sort of conclusion to the
speech so that you're not just standing
there going well that's all folks
that's not really a conclusion you want
to like have an action item or something
like that so Aristotle saying in
understood in this sense one thing is
prior to another like in good speech
writing so what about in the sciences
here he uses an example and remember
Aristotle was not only an investigator
but also a teacher he says in science is
using demonstration we have what is
prior in its order and what is pair
contra posterior that is one thing is is
brought up first and we're going to lead
the student or lead the other person who
are trying to demonstrate something to -
what is posterior we're going to be
again for example from starting points
that people can agree to or from ideas
that seem simpler and then we're going
to work into conclusions that they might
not have accepted right off the bat but
given those starting points we can we
can lead them to that so you know he
says for example in geometry what do we
start with points lines things that we
call elements and then we move on to
propositions or problems so we go from
the simpler or the easier to grasp or
the more evidence to the the more
complex the less evident the harder to
grasp that is an order so we said some
things are prior other things are
posterior notice we're not saying that
necessarily those things that a prior
came first in time we're not actually
saying that they they are you know
required by the very nature of their
being sometimes these can coincide but
sometimes we might have an arrangement
of being where one thing is prior but we
actually talk about things in a way that
reverses that priority he also gives the
example of words and syllables and
letters we begin from simpler things
combine them the simpler things in this
case are actually prior we combine them
into syllables that actually sounds a
bit more like this order of being so
there could be a little confusion there
in the fourth type he says this is
something that the common people
speaking about who they hold in esteem
or affection this is the way they talk
but this is a very strange he says
strange use it calls it although three
Oh tato's you know the most foreign way
or though does you know the weirdest way
of talking about this but it does make
sense
when we talk about having affection or
esteem or giving somebody honor we are
in a certain sense putting them first we
are making them prior
so if you honor your parents or
grandparents or the founders of your
your club or university or whatever you
are you're making them prior they could
also come before you in time but that is
not necessarily the case
so sometimes priority means something
like this and Aristotle says we have
those people first in our hearts as an
example then he goes on and there's a
long discussion of a fifth kind he says
these are I think the four distinct
senses in which we may use the word pry
the term prior but another might seem to
exist beyond those we've already
mentioned what would this other be so he
starts getting into some interesting
technical terms recess in the case of
two things where the existence of either
implies or necessitate the other that
thing which is somehow the cause and
here he uses the term cause hi Fiona
this is very important
he's talking here about something that
ties in with his conception of causality
actually should be ideally one thing by
being the cause in in whatever way of
the other one thing who's being
necessitates or or implies the being of
the other is prior to it look at the
example that he uses here this is a very
interesting one instead of saying things
having to do with what we call efficient
causality like you know well the maker
is prior to the made thing or the form
is prior to the you know the thing
itself or the end that it's seeking and
final causality no he talks here about
something else he says such cases can
clearly be found the existence of a man
for example necessitates the truth of
the statement wherein we assert his
existence the converse is also the case
if he exists then the statement
asserting the fact will be true if this
stateman conversely is true then the man
referred to must exist but the true
statement is not the cause of the man's
existing rather the existing is the
cause of the true statement so the
person existing is prior in this sense
to the statement about them existing or
the statement being true about that
existing this takes a little bit of
wrapping your head around and you might
say well doesn't that fall into this
thing right here the order of being this
has to do more with sequence a there's
an argument that could be made that we
could roll this into the second kind but
Aristotle by the end of this section
says so we can conclude there really
five senses we started with four and we
wound up with five we've picked up an
extra along the way but this is the way
that philosophical thinking about
complex topics really works